das ist wirklich unglaublich bisher
wurde es nur vermutet jetzt wurde es
durch versuche bestätigt spinnen können
sich mittels elektrischer felder
fortbewegen und wie sie das machen dass
es wirklich sensationell also jetzt wie
es funktioniert und wie weit die spinnen
damit kommen den krieg ziehen science
fiction herzlich willkommen
wir haben ja lässt sich darüber
berichtet wie einfach effektiv und
schnell evolution funktioniert in afrika
gibt es immer mehr elefanten ohne
stoßzähne dafür sorgen die wilderer die
die elefanten mit stoß sind töten
die zeugen so weniger nachkommen und die
ohne stoßzähne dafür umso mehr und schon
sorgt diese auslese für das langsame
aussterben der elefanten mit stoßzähnen
es ist schon eigentlich ziemlich simpel
es überleben immer die lebewesen mit
leicht besseren eigenschaften und bilden
dann irgendwann die mehrheit und zum
schluss sterben die anderen aus es
bleiben im fall der elefanten diejenigen
ohne stoßzähne übrig außer die
umweltbedingungen ändern sich irgendwann
in diesem fall wäre es das beenden der
wilderei ja und für die spinnen bedeutet
das dass arten die sich verbreiten
können einen deutlichen vorteil
gegenüber arten haben die sich nicht
verbreiten können oder deutlich
langsamer ausbreiten können was hat sich
die natur dafür ausgedacht bzw
was ist entstanden welche eigenschaft
hat die auslese entwickelt flügel haben
ich bin ja nicht und so haben sie eine
wirkliche high end technologie
entwickelt die sie ohne wind fliegen
lässt und das ist wirklich extrem
spannend beobachtet wurde das seltsame
flugverhalten der baldachin spinnen
schon vor langer zeit schon charles
darwin beobachtete wie hunderte kleine
spinnen an einem windstillen tag auf
seinem expeditionsschiff be gelandeten
und mit hoher geschwindigkeit wieder
davon flogen und schon im neunzehnten
jahrhundert wurde spekuliert dass die
spinnen mithilfe elektrostatischer
kräfte flogen doch erforscht hat und
dass bisher niemand und so war es reine
spekulation jetzt hat eine
forschungsgruppe der university of
bristol das geheimnis gelüftet und es
ist wirklich spektakulär
basis war das elektrische feld dass
zwischen der oberen atmosphäre und dem
erdboden besteht bei gewittern können
wir sogar einladung zwischen den beiden
polen des feldes beobachten wenn es
blitzt die stärke des feldes ist also
sehr unterschiedlich und nicht immer
können spinnen es deshalb nutzen doch
dem team gelang es ein so schwaches
fällt oder richtig schwaches feld
aufzubauen das genau die bedingungen
widerspiegelte die die spinnen zum
fliegen benötigen sie konnten das hält
zudem an
abschalten dann setzen sie die spinnen
in diesem raum auf eine startplattform
und achteten darauf dass es keinerlei
luftbewegung gab und tatsächlich
schalteten sie das feld an hoben die
spinnen abschalteten sie es aus sanken
sie langsam zu boden die baldachinspinne
nutzen dazu eine wirklich ausgeklügelte
technik sie recken ihr hinterteil in die
luft dann stoßen sie mehrere fäden aus
fächern sie auf und das elektrische feld
lässt sie abheben ihr kennt das
vielleicht aus eigener erfahrung wenn
kleidung aus kunststoff aufgeladen ist
dann werden die körperhaare angezogen
auch sie haben quasi ab die natur hat
daraus eine flugtechnik konstruiert
jetzt will das forschungsteam das
phänomen weiter untersuchen können die
spinnen zum beispiel dem flug durch
verlängern abwerfen der fäden und so
weiter beeinflussen wie weit fliegen sie
ja vermutet werden hunderte kilometer
weit
es gibt also noch viel zu klären wenn er
keine videos dazu und zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollen dann endet mich
bei whatsapp dann umgeht er die kaputte
aber boxee auf youtube und verpasst kein
video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
noch vor allen anderen als ich schicke
euch vorher eine nachricht vom neuesten
video täglich garantiert einfach darauf
blicken und am besten auch mein
schwesterkanal klicks um social media
abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus
der social media welt dafür da klicken
aber nicht die genau die glocke
vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken gefährliche
mückenart in deutschland bis dann bleibt
dran